ALSO. AS YOU JUST GOT TO CATCH
ELEVATE, YOU DON'T HAVE TIME
TO MAKE A PLAY.
>> REEVES REEVES GOT TO GET IT
IN 3 POINT COUNTRY. IT'S TO ON
ITS WAY. HE'S GOT IT.
>> THAT'S WHY SHOULD BE IN THE
GATE. YOU NEED SOMEONE CAN
JUST CATCH LET FLY. AND HE'S
SHOWN THAT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
STAY IN HIS HAND VERY LONG.
THEY'LL REVIEW IT. BUT IT
LOOKED LIKE A GOOD SHOT. A
LEGAL SHOT. AND SHOCKED. I
THINK ANOTHER LOOK AT ALL THE
SCREENING THAT'S GOING ON. I
I'VE SEEN 1000. IT'S
DEFINITELY GOING TO COUNTERS
TIME ALL OVER THE CLOCK. I'M
MUCH WE GOT TO A COACHES
CLINIC. WHY WERE YOU WORRIED
ABOUT A SCREEN WHEN YOU HAVE A
THREE-POINT LEAD WITH ONE 0ND
TO PLAY PLAY ON TOP. IF THEY
GO TO THE BASKET, SO BE IT
DISCREET SHOULD NEVER COME
INTO PLAY. YOU PLAY ON. OF ALL
THE SCREENS PLAYING UNDERNEATH
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO
SWITCH. UNBELIEVABLE. AND
LEARN. I'VE SEEN IT ALL IN THE
NBA. WE GO TO AN 5 MINUTE